hey it's a day here hey it's Tom one I'm
Jacob Athlon and we're about to do our
wired autocomplete
yes Tom Holland do his own stunts I do
actually I do do my own stunts but there
are some stunts that I can't do and then
I ask why I have my stunt double Greg
and Luke who are incredibly talented and
have made some of the action sequences
in this film I would say the most
memorable so I do my own stunts but I
can't take full credit the biggest
spoiler of the movie the biggest fan I
like the Studio Ghibli films yeah
totally spirited away like one of my
favorite films ever done okay you showed
me that film need glasses
mmm I do me too well I'm wearing right
now no I don't actually
it's a fashion statement anyway what
does in there's oh man oh yeah oh no
don't like how this car feels on my
nails I'm so brave it means to give
thanks
oh okay what is in there oh you know
it's something like what is in their
zodiac sign what is in Dez song replay
about what the so we were jamming out in
2016 oh no no no that was an hour
everyone what is in bears dog's name
like afternoon chocolate is Jacob from
Hawaii yeah yes yeah yes yes
no but you have to be determined yeah
but those were like space dogs that was
like kill or be killed and also we don't
know that instant kill means to actually
kill things we had this no no we had a
joke where it was like instant kill
kills anything electric like it's like a
kill switch but anyway I'm sure in the
comics you like Sunshine's right those
spider-man scratch oh the spider-man
wear shoes nice nice
does he wear those shoes in the movie no
no darn weird inspired I think where
everyone else went when they got stopped
but where did everyone else go into the
they went to Canada nice who is in there
wasn't a MC you cans and dad you can do
yeah cans and there's own question to
you yes how did Tom Holland honestly
it's making me feel really strange well
it's a long story but I'll tell him I've
been working out with Donna we worked
out together a whole bunch yeah we just
went to the gym Jacob and I together but
on this film Mike I tried to get really
bulky and I'm not gonna do that again
cuz I don't think I think I looked in
worse shape in this film that I did in
the first film it's got to eat a lot of
food yeah I was a bit like thicker I
[Music]
found out on Instagram Noboru I found
out on Instagram and then I ran
downstairs celebrating and I said to my
brother Harry as I do - dude I got the
part man play spider-man because at this
point like we'd come to terms I hadn't
got it yes I was told at the audition if
you get the part
you'll be filming on Monday and this was
six weeks after my audition so I'd sort
of accepted that I hadn't got it and
then he was like dude there's no way
that's true they've been hacked some
great news you're gonna be spider-man
and I was as I have to be honest Kevin I
already know
no heads-up and I'm Tom Holland get
famous weird question you're welcome I
get more compliments on the lip-sync
battle than I do
any of my actual work like now I'm like
over it a good time how does Tom Holland
say croissant yes it's a course on but
you do say it with a quack quack we're
saw quacks are you guys is trying to be
your friend
you're trying to be friends crystal I'm
like no but that's closer to how the
French people say it so who why are you
saying that you're saying because that's
just the way English people say is it
yeah when is Jacob bottle on bottle and
birthday October 9th I'm not gonna
totally hear how old is Jacob on Solano
um next question
man Jacob on Twitter
no but I do this like random one-off
thing where I talk to people and then I
leave because I'm like a mysterious yeah
just people that's where crazy it's too
many amazing and loving so how does
India pronounce your name you just said
how did zendaya start a career
hey how does the MS dress light up how
tall isn't Destin how flexible is
college I didn't we're about walk his
dogs want people coming on my dog walks
a minute what a thought where did Tom on
road in London where Tom Holland when
acting that was born an actor
all over the world in Ireland in Canada
in LA yes yeah yes webs
I mean spider-man which came out iTunes
play guitar strum along I can I can
that's how I got jacked